m
[Música]
volodymyr era un estudiante de la
academia militar de janovic tenía sólo
22 años el día del ataque ruso estaba
con el resto de sus compañeros
ah
en la iglesia de la guarnición de los
santos apóstoles pedro y pablo del ibi
se celebran funerales cada día desde que
empezó el ataque ruso no hay tregua en
esta guerra que deja viudas huérfanos y
madres sin hijos
el cura román men tu conocía volodymyr y
al resto de soldados de la región a los
que acompaña cada día
lo más difícil es de entender que yo a
ese chico lo conocía en persona y que a
él como a muchos otros soldados que he
conocido no tendré la oportunidad de
verlos de nuevo o tomarme un café con
ellos o hablar
efe
taras es un seminarista greco-católico
que ha vivido desde el primer día esta
guerra que empezó en el 2014 por amar su
país su gente
porque quería su país de verdad qué
es que me duele cuando los jóvenes como
yo
de 20 bueno yo tengo 26 pero eso es que
tienen menos que yo 20 años o 2022 que
han muerto en la guerra en la guerra por
ucrania
la guerra es también una madre que llora
[Música]
el cementerio del ibi fue destrozado
durante la segunda guerra mundial ahora
vuelve a los soldados caídos en la
guerra de rusia en ucrania
en ucrania la muerte y la destrucción
forman parte del paisaje diario como la
sirena de una ambulancia o la de una
alerta antiaérea
[Música]